on March 10th 2023 meta announced that
they would no longer be offering bonuses
to real creators on Instagram or
Facebook this was a massive surprise
given that everyone else was doubling
down on short form content in order to
compete against Tik Tok but Zuckerberg
had chosen to go against the grain and
pull back on short form content why well
promoting Wheels was actually losing
meta quite a bit of Revenue it turns out
that people scrolling through reels is a
lot less Prof profitable than people
scrolling through the Instagram feed
$500 million less per quarter or $2
billion less per year to be precise
hearing this you're probably inclined to
think that rules were taking a massive
toll on Instagram's Top Line and that's
why they decided to pull back after all
if this was WhatsApp that $2 billion
toll would be twice their total annual
revenue but the same cannot be said
about Instagram in fact it's actually
the exact opposite with Instagram in
2023 Instagram is expected to pull in
just over $50 billion in Revenue let me
put that in perspective that's $20
billion more than YouTube $37 billion
more than Tik Tok and over 11 times more
than Snapchat in fact Instagram is the
second most lucrative social media
platform in the world only beaten out by
Facebook themselves so out of all the
players that are pursuing short form
content Instagram is actually the most
well off and that $2 billion toll only
transl Ates to 4% of their annual
revenue so Zuckerberg's decision to pull
back from shorts is less of a financial
move and more of a strategic move of
course he's not just going to remove
reels alt together from the platform and
stay completely out of the loop but it's
clear that he would rather continue to
focus on core Instagram products and
treat reals as an addition to the
business as opposed to the future of the
business and given how well Instagram is
already doing this is definitely a
strategic calculated choice but all of
this still leaves the question how in
the world does Instagram make so much
money off of just pictures in the first
place to understand how Instagram became
so lucrative we first have to take a
look back at its roots which take us
back to 2009 to a young man named Kevin
cam Kevin was your classic High
achieving Tech bro the man started off
by attending Stanford where he majored
in management science and engineering
before turning around and interning at
Odo which is what would eventually turn
into Twitter before finally getting a
job at Google as you can see Kevin was
truly an elite Tech bro so I don't think
you'd be surprised to hear that the idea
for Instagram actually came rather
naturally during a vacation it turns out
that his girlfriend didn't want to post
vacation pictures on social media
because she felt that the pictures
weren't high quality enough Kevin's
solution to this was to just throw on a
a few filters and this is what would
lead to the idea of Instagram though it
was originally called bourbon from there
it didn't take long for Kevin to put
together a prototype for bourbon and a
pigeot to a few VCS at a local party the
VCS would agree to fund him with
$500,000 allowing him to quit his job
and go all in on Bourbon initially
though it seems that Kevin was actually
all over the place he wanted the app to
do as much as possible from checking
into hotels to earning points for
attending social events it wasn't a to
one of his college friends Mike creger
joined that their Vision became a lot
more focused Mike was adamant that
people did not want a complicated app
and that Simplicity was key as such the
duo would decide to hone in on just
photo sharing and to make that as
polished as possible and eventually on
October 6th 2010 Instagram would be
launched on the app store within just
the first day itself Instagram would
rack up 25,000 users by the end of the
first week this turned into 100,000
users and by mid December this turned
into 1 million users one of the main
reasons for this explosive growth was
Instagram's Crystal Clear Focus which
translated into a crystal clear
demographic which is the first reason
that Instagram is so lucrative their
demographic is not only crystal clear
but it's also highly monetizable just
think about it what type of person is
most likely to use Instagram with
YouTube it's basically everyone as
YouTube serves all sorts of content from
Comedy and gaming to education and
finance at first glance it seems that
Instagram also serves all sort of
content but when we take a step back and
look at the overarching picture one
adjective comes to mind aspirational
more times than not people don't go on
to Instagram to look at something truly
funny or entertaining or educative like
they might with YouTube they go on to
Instagram to look at things that they
don't have whether it's the perfect body
or the perfect relationship or the
perfect vacation or the perfect wealth
and the fact that people people only
post highly doctored curated versions of
themselves only place into this
phenomena this is why Instagram is
commonly cited as the worst social media
for mental health but while this sucks
for users it's perfect for the platform
as this creates the perfect breeding
ground for advertisers to play into
users insecurities and dreams and
maximize on conversion rates when you
combine this context with the resources
and influence of Facebook well all of
this just gets put into
overdrive
Facebook got involved with Instagram
pretty early on just 18 months after
launch in fact in April of 2012 Facebook
would buy out the entire company for
just $1 billion which at the time seemed
like a massive amount but Zuckerberg
clearly knew what he was doing after the
acquisition Kevin was for the most part
allowed to run Instagram as an
independent business that simply had
access to the resources of of Facebook
which was extremely powerful Instagram
had the agility and speed of a small
startup but also the resources and
backing of a social media Giant and
Kevin would make great use of this by
venturing into the world of copying
there's really no easy way to put this
with the help of Facebook Instagram
would just go around and blatantly rip
off features from the competition the
most blatant examples of this are of
course stories igtv and reals but there
are dozens of smaller examples
usually there's no point in suing when
it comes to Tech because even if you
somehow win the court case the infringer
will probably get the last laugh if
Instagram was still just a startup maybe
the competition would have at least
tried though but since they were not
part of Facebook no one even bothered
giving Instagram a free rign experiment
with whatever feature they wanted
Instagram was never adamant about any
one of these features though they always
had the approach of let's see how users
respond and how this affects the
business overall before making a
decision pulling back on reals is just
the latest example of this just 2 years
ago they completely scrapped the idea of
longform content through igtv because
according to themselves users just
weren't using it this freedom to
experiment with anything and everything
with little repercussions and
consequences gave Instagram the
opportunity to really find the most
successful and lucrative features and
double down on them but all of that only
tells half the story as Facebook brought
something even more important to
Instagram advertisers before Facebook
got involved Instagram didn't even have
advertising in fact it's not clear if
Instagram made any Revenue at all but
Facebook would Chang this in November of
2013 Instagram would show off their
first sponsored post an ad from Michael
Kors users weren't too happy with this
ad but Michael Kors was in fact within
just the first 18 hours Michael korus
would gain 34,000 new followers
Instagram ads are obviously nowhere near
as effective today as users have gotten
used to them but compared to other
platforms Instagram is still Miles Ahead
the average cost per ad click on
Instagram comes in at
$356 which is even higher than YouTube
which comes in at
$321 this is especially surprising given
that on YouTube ads usually come in the
format of unskippable videos on
Instagram on the other hand you can
easily scroll past any AD so you would
think that getting clicks on YouTube
would be more expensive but it's
actually more expensive on Instagram
largely because of their demographics
and context it's a lot easier to sell a
product to someone who wants to be
something else as opposed to someone who
just wants to get to the video already
as such the only Social Network that has
a higher cost per click than Instagram
is LinkedIn but that's a whole another
Beast between the freedom to experiment
and opportunity to leverage first class
advertising it seemed like Kevin's
partnership with socer ber was going
quite well but this honeymoon phase
didn't last
forever as Instagram started doing
better and better and even started out
chining Facebook itself the company
started having some serious internal
Politics the Instagram team felt that
Facebook got a steal with the
acquisition and that they were the
future of Facebook meanwhile the
Facebook team felt that the only reason
that in was so successful in the first
place was because of Facebook's backing
and as you would guess this drama went
all the way to the top to Mark
Zuckerberg and Kevin cyrm eventually it
got to the point that Zuckerberg just
wanted Kevin and Mike to leave so that
he could take the reign of both Facebook
and Instagram and reunite the companies
Zuckerberg didn't want to fly out to
fire these guys though so instead he was
just starting cutting resources and
implementing changes that would piss
them off for example when Kevin was on
paternity leave Z Zuckerberg would
Implement location tracking and
hamburger menus into the app two
features that Kevin was strongly against
and eventually Zuckerberg would come out
on top and both Kevin and Mike would
leave but being the Undisputed king of
both Instagram and Facebook wasn't the
only place that Zuckerberg didn't have
to share one major advantage that we
have yet to discuss is that Instagram
doesn't have to share any of their ad
Revenue with their creators largely
because their creators aren't After Cash
directly more times than not the main
goal of Instagram users whether it's the
popular kid in high school or some
massive celebrity is to boost popularity
and stay relevant as opposed to making
money of course making money is often
part of it but with Instagram it's more
of something that follows as opposed to
something that leads as such the fact
that Instagram doesn't share Revenue
with their creators isn't something that
really turns away creators of course
there are some exceptions to this and
Instagram does pay creators under
certain circumstances but when it comes
to the Main feed Instagram gets to keep
all the ad Revenue which obviously makes
a massive Difference YouTube shares
basically half of all the revenue with
creators this means that the total
revenue that YouTube pulls in is not 30
billion but actually closer to 60
billion or higher than Instagram as you
would expect so why is Instagram so
lucrative well they have a unique
aspirational demographic that's perfect
for advertising they've been able to
experiment with every format Under the
Sun to find the most lucrative and
successful formats and historically they
haven't had to share much revenue with
creators when you combine all of this
you end up with over $50 billion in
annual revenue meta as a whole pulls in
$126 billion in annual revenue and
they're worth just over 800 billion and
if we were to translate this ratio over
to Instagram it would mean that
Instagram is worth over $300 billion by
themselves and that's why Instagram is
the real winner when it comes to short
form content there not staying out of
the loop by ditching Wheels altogether
but at the same time they're also not
willing to cannibalize their main
business in order to make reals work
with historically High interest rates
the appeal of bills and bonds is higher
than ever yet traditional brokerages
haven't really adapted with the times
they still expect people to use clunky
Bond tables scroll through long
overwhelming lists and even use Virtual
keyboards till recently and that's why
we created our own modern Bond platform
form Silo at Silo we prioritize the user
experience and the ease of finding and
investing in the issuers you know and
trust so that you too can easily lock in
high yields also choosing a strong user
experience does not mean sacrificing
unsafety every Salo account is insured
by $500,000 in sipc insurance and $2.5
million in FDIC Insurance also all funds
deposited on the platform will be
maintained by our trusted custodian
interactive brokers who has experienced
managing $373 billion worth of assets
over the past 45 years so if you're
looking for a modern way to invest in
bonds please consider checking out Silo
in the description below it doesn't seem
like YouTube got this memo because
that's precisely what they've been doing
check out this video to learn more but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next
one